Speaker 1: Let's go back to the phones, by
which I mean discord.
We take calls on Fridays at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
We are going to go next to Julian in New York
City.
Julian, what's going on?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I just well, a couple
of weeks ago, I heard your interview with
Anand Giridharadas and the Persuaders book,
which I. Anand.
I'm on on it.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I guess the emphasis is at the beginning.
I got I got it on to two off the air with
them.
Anand.
Yes, Anand.
Speaker 2: Wonderful.
Well, here again, I mean, fantastic.
Fantastic interview.
Really?
I thought, you know, one of your best in the
past year.
But I read his book, The Persuaders, and one
of my favorite sections was Democratic messaging
or about Democratic messaging with the recent
wins in the Senate, you know, expanding the
majority, all that.
What do we how do we keep pushing Democrats
and, I guess, larger progressive communities
to to keep because, you know, the messaging
is an issue.
It's still an issue.
Oh, yeah, we won.
But we we still have this huge problem that
is sort of like a I don't know, it's like
a virus that doesn't seem to you know, I guess
my question is, where is it going?
How do we build this incentive to keep pushing
our community in the right direction?
Speaker 1: Well, listen, when you say the
messaging, are you talking about messaging
from elected Democrats or from people ancillary
to the Democratic Party like progressive activists?
Or who what messaging exactly are you referring
to?
Speaker 2: I think it starts at the top and
then works its way down.
I mean, it can start, you know, anywhere from
Bernie.
And then and then it flows down.
It's this it's this framing things.
Conceding these crazy made up points that
Republicans say about either the border or
whatever.
Speaker 1: Well, give me an example of that.
So like, whether it's Bernie or whatever,
what's what's the point that the left has
conceded on the border?
Speaker 2: Like Republicans will say, okay,
there there are you know, so many illegal
immigrants are crossing the border.
And then Democrats will say, we're going to
we're going to be just as strong on the border,
but we're also going to make sure that new
jobs and and stuff is being so, you know,
like in encountering that point, they're not
they're not they're conceding that they're
that that they too we, too, want to be strong
at the border.
And that's I mean.
Speaker 1: I think that simple because there's
an opposite.
So there's two different issues here.
It's the the reason why it's really hard to
say.
Here's the way to frame this.
And I'm not a framing guy you need the truth
is you need to figure out what would actually
be effective here.
There's like three different issues at the
border that are from a rhetoric standpoint
and a propaganda standpoint.
One is the story that the day Trump left and
Biden took over, something dramatically changed
that.
The border that now allows a free flow of
undocumented immigrants over the border, that
that didn't happen.
Right.
So that that's one issue that you have to
deal with.
Number two is the issue of it is because of
Republicans getting in the way that significant
immigration reform hasn't been done.
A lot of low hanging fruit could have been
dealt with.
DOCA could have been dealt with with a path
to citizenship for those who came here when
they weren't even adults.
They were just brought here by parents.
It's Republicans who have gotten in the way
of that to some degree because they they see,
oh, we don't want to give Democrats that victory
or whatever the case may be.
So there's that issue as well.
And then number three, there's the Republican
I don't know what to call it, but it's oh,
there's an election coming up.
Well, then we should talk about caravans.
And then all of a sudden, the day after the
election, we don't mention caravans anymore.
And there's an election coming up.
We got to talk about violent crime by undocumented
immigrants the day after the election.
They don't talk about it anymore.
So there's that brazen hypocrisy when it comes
to when they even claim to care.
It's a lot to deal with.
I don't have the right messaging on it.
I don't know.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Yeah.
And I guess to sort of summarize, what I'm
what I'm trying to say is it feels like we're
always playing catch up with the messaging.
They say something, they state something.
It can be blatantly false.
And then we don't even, you know, disprove
it.
We just go with it.
And.
Yes, and rather than really putting our foot
down.
And so with the recent wins, I just I just
want to make sure that we keep a pressure
on.
Speaker 1: I agree with you.
I just don't know who it is that is well positioned
like maybe it's on and I don't know to give
some advice about what should the language
be around some of these issues to fight the
Republican framing, which is so dishonest
and inaccurate?
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Well, thanks very much, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
All right.
Great to.
Great to hear from Julian in New York City.
Why don't we go next to.
Oh, I don't know.
How about a rose calling from the United States?
God bless the United States.
Rose, Rose, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
I owe you an apology for last time.
Speaker 1: That sounds great.
Let's start there.
What?
What did you do wrong?
Speaker 2: I interrupted you.
But while you're talking, I have ADHD and
some time, so I do that.
We're talking about space.
So here's.
Here's my point.
I've been feeling more and more that we are
hurtling towards a future that most of us
aren't even prepared for, let alone dreaming,
dreaming about.
So are you aware about, like, the general
risk profile around nuclear proliferation?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
In fact, I recently read the book Precipice
by Toby Ord, wherein he talks about existential
risks to Homo sapiens and devotes quite a
bit of time to to sort of a nuclear I don't
know what you would even call it, a nuclear
holocaust, for lack of a better term.
Yes.
So to some degree, I've read about it.
Speaker 2: So there's been though back in
the 1960s, there was this project called the
Emmet's Country Project where they gave to
grad student.
One of them left him.
So it was in three.
Three grad students in total recently graduated
almost no experience a library and access
to basic technical help and basic calculations.
This was 1960, so that meant computer time
and asked them to come up with a working schematics
for an implosion style device.
That was like the atom bomb used in Nagasaki,
the Fatboy.
It's like a sphere of plutonium and explodes.
There's explosive lenses around it and the
explosion goes off in, like, precise nanosecond
timing and it, like, compresses the sphere
into a tiny ball and causes fission and then
boom.
They managed to create a working model from
scratch in two and a half years to create
a working schematic from two and a half years
that was meant to see if how long would it
take a nation state to do this to end its
country at a time only the US and the USSR
could do it.
Reason Most of the information needed to build
a weapon like this has always been open source.
It's like 80 year old technology, but the
constraint has always been the materials.
But now it feels like it's getting easier
and easier and easier to do it.
I was just playing the shot shipped here.
Yes.
And I managed to get it to do certain things,
including automatically generate certain things
related to this technology.
One might say that it would have ordinarily
taken me weeks of research to do, and it did.
Speaker 1: Not.
Sure I know what you're saying, and I'm not
sure if there's a question.
Are you saying that you were in a conversation
with this chat bot chat GPT, you were able
to get information from it, which presumably
it sourced from available information about
how to build a nuclear device.
Is that what you're saying?
Speaker 2: It synthesized it.
It took what would have been like weeks of
synthesis and did it in 10 seconds.
Speaker 1: Understood.
And then it kind of like spat out information
about how such such a device might be built.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: Dimensions are different parts
and so on, like how to calculate the dimensions
of code for it and so on and how to simulate
it.
I feel like a lot of the conversation that
I've had with conservatives and so on in the
future that they imagine it is really disconnected
with the future that we we have in the future
that I'm seeing coming.
Like when I saw that, it actually really shocked
me.
So I had this moment of future shock, you
know, like, I wish my mom.
Speaker 1: Would get it.
Rose, did did you have a question today?
Speaker 2: Yes.
What do you feel about this?
Is there a way to bridge that disconnect?
Is this area.
Speaker 1: Which disconnect are you referring
to.
Speaker 2: Between most people in the future
that is coming and just trying to convey to
them that, hey, the stuff we're fighting over,
it's it's it's not exactly the most prosaic
of issues.
Speaker 1: No, I don't have any insights as
to how one might do that.
I mean, we all there's I've talked before
this idea where, you know, if we made first
contact with an intelligent alien species,
all of a sudden we would all realize that
our earthly problems are really quite meaningless
in the grand scheme of things, and finding
other intelligent life and war would end.
And then, you know, I've spoken to enough
scientists who say, yeah, that wouldn't really
happen.
It would sort of maybe temporarily do that.
And then things would go back to the exact
same debates and disagreements that we have
and people can't sort of more permanently
be in that mindset.
So I don't have any great insights as to how
to connect people with the potential future
were hurtling towards.
I wish I did.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much.
And I shall read the book.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
All right.
There is Rose.
Very, very important message and making a
lot of different claims, I would say